change lives I'm data via angeleyes
change organizations guy vs he
organization in Japan is also might
change the world you first have to start
by changing yourself our students are
going to be facing situations in which
yesterday's answers are no longer
relevant so they in a sense have to seek
out new solutions to the new problems
are facing change lives checking role
while i tenderly change lives when it
comes to hard skills i have been able to
learn all about how businesses run what
are the important things that i need to
run my own business in future but the
more powerful aspect is the soft skills
i've never been to an educational
setting where I felt so care for and so
invested it the Jews views an
environment where you're allowed to
experiment a lot it's open to people
taking risks it means that students are
naturally encouraged innovate everybody
around you has this confidence in you
that you will be successful change lives
didn't give me but love change lives
change lives in the classroom outside
the classroom we have so so much of
interaction going on you have people who
start their own companies you have
people have been film director give
people who are bankers and private
equity folks and consultants but you
have just this diversity of backgrounds
that really makes a big difference my
study group is comprised of a German a
polish gentlemen canadian-american a
French woman I mean it's just really
amazing that is one of the most
beautiful thing about GSB people from 52
different culture you don't have time
for pie shop there you just have to
observe at the GSP every student is
required to participate in at least one
global experience a part of the world
that's new to them so I just came back
from the Stanford Shanghai exchange
program beijing i was on a global study
trip to kenya
one night I went to the Austrian citizen
global study trip in the classroom you
can learn about culture and you can
learn about how Indian society is so
different from the US and you get some
appreciation of that and then you spend
ten minutes on the ground here and it
all of a sudden it makes sense it smell
it I taste it today we visited they all
india institute medicine you have to see
the crowds you have to see how hard the
doctors are where we have to see the
hospital's you have to just see the
nurse is caring for the patient and the
family surrounding their loved ones that
is just something you can't get from a
textbook it's very easy to talk about it
30,000 feet then it's another to talk
about it in terms of three feet when a
student comes to another country a
developing country and they see the
immensity of the challenge they develop
a much broader perspective broaden their
heart and are moved and inspired to take
action one of the things that our
students are interested in doing is
finding business opportunities that have
meaningful impact little difference in
the lives of hundreds millions of
people's GSP experience by virtue of the
subject by virtue of the professors by
virtue of the people by virtue of my
fellow students has been extremely
transformative it's really about empathy
and understanding
people you're trying to lead I think
Stanford's really helped me in that
sense because it makes you think not
just for systems and processes but also
people gsbs given me a lot of skill sets
I feel really empowered what I learned I
the GSP is completely can be applied
here in China it changes your
perspective on what you can accomplish
and how you can impact people it's the
totality of the NBA experience that
really cooks our students for a life of
meaning and impact as a result of a
personal transformation